the next time I feel like parenting is hard
I'm gonna remind myself how much harder it is
parenting three children on the side of a mountain
at 0 degrees
while they're flying at speed on skis
compared to that, the day to day is a
walk in the fkn park
it's day three in Queenstown
and it's just occurred to me that the last time my children saw snow
was six years ago
it was 2018, I was pregnant with baby girl
and the boys were six and four
so olive has never encountered snow
and the first thing she wanted to do was eat it, naturally
we got all of our shit where it needed to be
which was a workout within itself
I was tired before we even began
and for some reason
I thought it would be a good idea if I taught the children how to ski myself
despite the fact that I haven't skied in about 15 years
Ok so I don't know if this is in my head or if it genuinely helped
but I feel like it genuinely helped? anyway
you know how I said I was keeping
this trip a surprise from the kids
well recently I dug out the rollerblades and the roller skates
and I got the kids on them for a couple hours a week for the last few weeks
and I could be wrong but I feel like it's kinda comparable to skiing
I was definitely pleasantly surprised
at how quickly they found their footing with the ski
we practice for a while in the beginners meadow
before taking them up the chairlift
and doing a few big runs
and little olive was just off like a rocket
which was both impressive and deeply concerning
every time somebody bailed
I tried unsuccessfully
to suppress a memory that I have
of watching my brother break his leg on a mountain
not too far from this one
while he was lying there
I fell through a hole in the ice
and nearly got dragged away by an underground stream
and he had the audacity to laugh
my poor fkn parents, that must have been the day from hell
no wonder they split up
And that's a roundabout way of saying
I was surprised at how much my inner child showed up today
I parent her almost as much as my actual children
I quietener her down with a mulled wine in a 65 degree sauna
which was actually insane
And because I literally devoured a court of thorns and roses
I’m onto book two
which I had to buy on the iPad cause I couldn't find it anywhere